bon je suis très heureux d'accueillir en
votre nom avant jean pierre rioux
qui va s'exprimer
après moi une minute mois une minute lui
et puis tout le reste du temps à jean
christophe rufin je suis très heureux
d'accueillir en votre nom jean
christophe rufin eux pour beaucoup de
raisons alors je vais tout de suite à
l'essentiel en tout cas pour marielle
pour moi jean christophe rufin est un
ami c'est quelqu'un avec qui nous avons
depuis longtemps
des réflexions partagées des échanges
bon de l'amitié des liens de ces liens
qui dépasse même les échanges
intellectuels l'admiration qu'ils sont
des liens d'affection et de respect
deuxièmement c'est une des personnalités
les plus riches
polyvalente
qu'on puisse trouver aujourd'hui dans le
paysage
comment on peut dire des élites
françaises
jean christophe rufin comme vous savez
de formation est médecin
et il s'est en particulier intéressé au
secteur de la psychiatrie
et puis
à la suite de quoi je fais vraiment un
très grand très il s'est passionné pour
l'humanitaire
à la fois action contre la faim dont il
a été le président et dont il est encore
le la référence
et médecins sans frontières
et puis ensuite il s'est intéressé au
développement
et il a notamment beaucoup travaillé sur
les échanges nord-sud sur
l'amérique latine
sur le rôle des ong dans la question du
développement
et le rôle des ong n'est pas comment
dire univoque
il ya bien des questions à poser aussi
autour du rôle des ong
et puis ensuite
sur le socle de cette expérience
médicale humanitaire
il a eu une très importante
responsabilité diplomatique puisqu'il a
été nommé ambassadeur de france au
sénégal
ce n'a pas été de tout repos
alors bien entendu le sénégal c'est un
pays tout à fait essentiel très
important
mais en même temps les autorités du
sénégal ont parfois eu des profils un
peu comment on peut dire
complexe
donc il a eu des accrochages avec les
autorités du sénégal à cette époque et
chaque fois qu'il y à un ambassadeur qui
parle franchement
les autorités du pays n'ont qu'une envie
qu'une urgence c'est de le voir dégager
le terrain
il ya donc eu comme ça de
d2 un peu d'acidité qui s'est exprimé
autour de la mission tout à fait
éminente que jean christophe rufin
remplissait
pendant ce temps dans toutes ces longues
années là jean christophe rufin s'est
exprimé d'une autre manière puisque
comme vous le savez
c'est un homme d'écriture c'est un des
plus grands écrivains français
et vous connaissez tous sont son oeuvre
et il a eu l'idée
tout cas l'impulsion le
de présenter sa candidature à l'académie
française où il a été élu et vous avez
devant vous celui qui est depuis déjà de
nombreuses années le plus jeune
académicien français
alors dans le plus jeune académicien
français il ya comme un oxymore
commandite pour les pour les littéraires
et donc
naturellement il ya là quelque chose de
tout à fait éminence ce qui fait que
bien entendu c'est pas seulement le plus
jeune académicien français mais c'est
aussi un de ceux qui par l'esprit et le
caractère vont dans les années qui
viennent jouer un rôle important pour
la place c'est l'expression de
l'académie française dans la société
française c'est donc vous le voyez
une un esprit et une personnalité très
polyvalente
connaissant très bien
le sujet dont nous allons parler
aujourd'hui et qui est un sujet brûlant
nous avions invité jean christophe rufin
avant mais le déclenchement de la guerre
au mali a naturellement donné à
l'expérience qui est la sienne et au
regard qui est le sien sur la réalité
africaine une acuité tout à fait
particulière une urgence tout à fait
particulière et c'est donc de ce sujet
que jean christophe rufin va nous
entretenir et nous sommes extrêmement
nous nous sommes extrêmement
reconnaissants de sa présence je
rappelle naturellement que cette session
vous êtes ici nombreux et sympathique
comme toujours
mais plus nombreux qu'eux que les autres
fois mais aussi sympathique de les
autres fois vous êtes ici la partie
émergée de l'iceberg puisque comme vous
le savez cette conférence est
retransmise sur internet et qu'il y aura
plus tard compte-rendu corrigé donc tu
peux t'exprimer en toute liberté
de cette séance c'est jean pierre rioux
qui maintenant va accueillir
jean christophe rufin
tiens je ne sais pas jean-pierre si ça
marche sinon je vous passe ça
normalement ça doit marcher mais
je salue à mon tour jean christophe
rufin qui nous fait l'honneur et le
plaisir d'être avec nous ce soir je n'ai
rien à ajouter à la présentation de 9
ans ce verrou sur
l'humanitaire
le
l'homme sans frontières
le diplomate
et l'écrivain et donc pour peut-être
introduire un peu la séance se soit de
manière
peut-être à la fois plaisante et
redoutable je vais remplir un peu mon
devoir d'état je suis historien vous le
savez et donc je vous lis un petit texte
ça prendra une minute rassurez vous
alors le voici
la prise de tombouctou est un événement
considérable sur lequel l'attention
publique doit être appelée n'est pas
loin d'avoir la même importance que la
prise d'alger que la prise d'alger dans
évidente il est la suite heureuse il
complique il complète l'oeuvre de
civilisation que la france a accompli en
afrique en refoulant de plus en plus
dans les solitudes saharienne les hordes
de pillards qui ont de tout temps
infesté cette partie du monde la prise
de tombouctou assurera l'avenir du
continent noir une troupe de braves
français dans les noms resteront
obscures pour la plupart a accompli ses
hauts faits d'armes qui donne à notre
patrie un bien autres lustres que le
discussions stériles des politiciens
donc c'était l'illustration du 24
février
1894 à l'occasion de la première fois où
nous si j'ose dire nous avons pris
tombouctou est l'illustration ajoute
nous faisons une guerre sans merci dans
une haute pensée de civilisation
monsieur l'ambassadeur
vous avez la pape
merci beaucoup bonsoir à tous
cher françois
je suis très heureux effectivement de
pouvoir venir m'exprimer ici
devant vous sur l'afrique
je ne descendent des montagnes
il y avait beaucoup de neige et où je
suis en train d'essayer d'écrire un
livre et je suis arrivé tout à l'heure
en me disant qu'au fond j'avais fait le
choix de ne pas parler de la de la
guerre au mali j'ai fait partie dans le
figaro mais à part ça je n'ai pas voulu
m'exprimer dans les médias sur ce sujet
puisque le démangeait tu es mon autre
chose et au fond je me suis dit comme ça
c'est très bien ça veut dire que
j'aurais réserver mes commentaires
pour françois bayrou et vous tous et
c'est donc à dire une occasion libre de
parler de ça dans une dans une période
qui
qui est un peu incertaine j'ai tiré et
si vous permettez je vais utiliser le
support sur scène je vais utiliser le
support d'un powerpoint que j'avais
j'utilise rarement cet instrument parce
que je le trouve un peu barbare mais
enfin parlant de l'afrique il a un grand
mérite c'est qu'ils permettent de
montrer une carte est donc peut-être de
mieux situer ce dont on va parler alors
pour le commenter je me mette debout
parce que dira je verrai pas de quoi il
s'agit mais vous non plus voilà alors eu
l'idée c'était de de prendre un peu de
champ par rapport aux événements
d'aujourd'hui c'est-à-dire cette guerre
qui ne sort pas de rien quand même et de
faire un petit retour en arrière sur ce
qui s'est passé dans cette région du
monde je parle essentiellement de
l'afrique de l'ouest depuis les
indépendances en gros disons depuis les
années 60
déjà tout de suite on peut observer une
chose quand on regarde cette carte quand
on regarde le mali c'est que on est et
le dire comme ça que je reviens toujours
à la géographie très important le mali
est situé exactement au milieu de cette
sous région de l'afrique de l'ouest
c'est à dire que la région dont nous
allons parler en ce qui concerne
l'intervention récente elle est entre
le maghreb qui a été secouée récemment
par les printemps arabes y compris par
une guerre était celle de libye et puis
l'afrique côtière l'afrique de l'ouest
côtières dont nous allons reparler et
c'est pour ça que je trouve nécessaire
s'ils voulaient quand on parle de la
situation au mali trouve nécessaire de
lier les deux c'est à dire de ne pas
parler du mali tout seul pas ce qui est
bien évident que ce qui se passe dans
cette dans ce pays ne peut pas être
isolé comme appartenant soit à l'afrique
subsaharienne soit à l'afrique du nord
mais combattants on en reparlera
islamistes d'antan dont on nous parle
beaucoup avec cette intervention
viennent à l'origine d'algérie donc ils
font un lien très net avec ce qui se
passe au maghreb et en même temps ce qui
est en question c'est la vie ou la
survie l'un des pays qui se trouve en
dessous sur la bande côtière donc on est
vraiment à la charnière de deux mondes
je trouvais intéressant je veux pas vous
faire un cours là dessus mais pour
présenter les choses et ensuite pouvoir
répondre à vos questions engager un
débat de reprendre les choses avec un
petit peu de profondeur de champ la fois
géographique et historique si vous
pouvez passer la photo suivante voilà ça
c'était une photo prise de de ma chambre
à
dakar et alors c'est très sympa comme ça
l'île de gorée mais je peux te dire que
tous les jours le beau temps au bout
d'un moment tu en as marre moi je suis
pas un homme du
enfin bref et c'est d'ailleurs pour ça
que un c'est pour ça que je suis un
savoir et surtout pour ça que je suis
rentré dans le berry tout de suite et
que j'ai écrit un livre sur jacques
coeur parce que ça me permettait j'ai
c'est très sympa pendant huit jours si
vous voulez mais moi j'ai besoin du
rythme des saisons du froid et enfin peu
importe en tout cas quelques éléments
historique par rapport à la première de
ces régions c'est à dire vous pouvez
remettre la carte un instant le teen de
revenir en arrière l'instant
non il n'écoute pas non là celle d'avant
la
voilà oui donc là on va parler de
l'afrique mais ces mobiles
high c'est formidable ça voilà donc pour
l'instant nous allons parler de
l'afrique subsaharienne l'afrique dite
afrique noire alors reprenons là alors
non voilà
trois étapes trois étapes qu'il faut
bien avoir à l'esprit quand on parle de
l'afrique
entre les indépendances entre 1960 en
gros et la fin du communisme soviétique
te dire 1990 en gros là encore
là le tableau de la situation africaine
était extrêmement contrastées vous aviez
une afrique de l'est c'est à dire la
corne de l'afrique
ethiopie somalie et du terrain qui était
très largement livrée à la guerre
vous aviez une afrique australe qui
était elle aussi très largement livrée à
la guerre en angola au mozambique etc et
puis vous aviez une afrique de l'ouest
et en particulier d'afrique francophone
de l'ouest qui était en quelque sorte
figée sous le boisseau avec une
décolonisation française qui s'était
faite de façon extrêmement particulière
très différente de la décolonisation
anglaise nous avions conservé des liens
très forts avec ces pays
nous avions exercé à plusieurs reprises
des ingérences plan les choses par leur
nom sur les régimes en place ou les
régimes que nous souhaitions mettre en
place et cette afrique de l'ouest
étaient calmes
connaissait la paix connaissez un
certain développement économique
indiscutable mais au prix d'une
sorte de glaciation politique avec de
vieux leader qui était en place depuis
toujours les senghor les vous faut être
boigny les ya des mamans
bhutto et d'autres qui en restait là et
qui ne tiennent pas sont garantis c'est
une forme d' équilibre de paix ce que
voudrait mais au prix encore une fois
d'une sorte de
vraiment d'immobilisme politique totale
ça c'est
1960 1990
à partir de 1990
changement de décor l'union soviétique
tombe les pays que je soutenais l'union
soviétique en particulier l'ethiopie
l'angola
le mozambique se retrouve d'une certaine
façon orphelins
l'apartheid va se terminer en afrique du
sud et au fond ces pays qui était livré
à la guerre en particulier l'angola
l'ouganda je veux dire qu'ils avaient
connus se souvenait amin dada enfin d
horreur absolue tous ces pays vont
sortir du marasme et entrait dans une
phase en tout cas de stabilité et
souvent de développement se veut pas
dire qu'ils aient plus de conflits dans
ces zones mais ça veut dire que quand
même ces pays sont sortis de la
tourmente est en revanche à partir de
1990 eh bien ce sont les pays d'afrique
de l'ouest qui vont connaître de très
grandes turbulences
ils vont connaître des turbulences qui
vont commencer avec une guerre dans un
pays que personne n'attendait qu'était
le libéria un pays qu'on cité en modèle
économique avec des chiffres de
développement qui sur le papier était
excellent et ce pays va exploser à
partir de 1989 et de neil young des
guerres civiles les plus épouvantables
qu'ils soient et qui d'ailleurs fera
essais mais la violence dans toute la
région puisqu'on retrouvera des
combattants libériens en côte d'ivoire
en guinée partout donc premier facteur
d'ébranlement je dirais cette guerre
civile au liberia
autre facteur d'ébranlement la fin des
vieux dictateur des vieux potentats pas
forcément dictateur mais enfin des vieux
potentat qui régnait
un certain nombre de ces pays pas tous a
toujours
cameroun en particulier ya toujours des
gens qui sont réélu avec des scores
enviable disons enfin
est depuis très longtemps mais dans
l'ensemble c'est vrai que cette afrique
de l'ouest a connu à ce moment là sous
l'impulsion de la france avec le fameux
discours de la baule rappelé
discours de mitterrand de la boule dix
ans au fond à cette démocratisation qui
était en marche dans toute l'europe de
l'est que les américains ensuite on
soutenue en amérique du sud eh bien il
faut que dans l'afrique francophone elle
se développe aussi et donc la
démocratisation est devenu le le maître
mot on a appelé ça la parisse troïka
pour faire pendant à la pérestroïka
c'était une sorte de révolution
culturelle avec des votes partout dans
des pays qui n'étaient pour la plupart
absolument pas préparé à ça
puisqu'il avait subi depuis des années
des dictatures ou en tout cas des
régimes très autoritaire il n'était
certainement pas habitué à l'exercice
démocratique sauf exceptions en
particulier le sénégal qui depuis
toujours et très très habitué à ce type
de d'activité mais dans d'autres pays
j'ai à dire cette démocratie
formelle à marche forcée s'est
transformé en vote ethnique avec des
déchirures extrêmement profonde la plus
grave évidemment se situant à la
périphérie de cette zone mais quand même
dans la zone francophone c'est à dire au
rwanda avec les massacres évidemment le
génocide rwandais qui n'est pas la seule
conséquence de démocratisation mais qui
en tout cas a été précipitée par là
l'entrée de ce pays dans une dans un
processus démocratique qui n'était pas
du tout maîtrisée donc pour me résumer
1960-1990 stabilité dans cette région et
à partir de 1990 au contraire jusqu'à
2010 au contraire une
une
entrée de ce pays dans des turbulences
très grave alors en mettant la carte un
instant ces turbulences ça a donné la
guerre au liberia je voulais dit une
contagion presque immédiate avec la
sierra leone guerre des diamants
connaissait
la côte d'ivoire a été secouée par le
même phénomène particulier dans l'ouest
mais qui ensuite évidemment a débouché
sur une crise politique
qui était latente dans le pays compte
tenu de sa composition ethnique
religieuse et qui a donné lieu là aussi
à une guerre civile très très grave
la guinée un petit peu plus tard la
guinée qui a toujours été un peu en
dehors c'est qu'elle a été elle est
restée en dehors du processus post
coloniale par l'option qu'avait prise
sékou touré de refuser la union
française et la guinée après disons les
derniers soubresauts du post sékou
tourisme on pourrait dire est entré dans
une dans une épouvantable guerre civile
aussi dans les années 2008 avec le
célèbre capitaine dadis que qui était un
qui était
on peut faire de pire dans le genre de
deux personnages d'incontrôlable la
guinée-bissau est un sort de narco état
qui a été dont le contrôle a été pris en
terme en terme de puissance publique par
les mafias essentiellement colombienne
puisque toutes là que la cocaïne qui
vient en europe arrive à large de la
guinée-bissau
la mauritanie
elle aussi a connu un processus très
difficile avec une démocratisation qui
en fait c'est développé qui a un peu
dérapé et qui a donné qui a donné un
boulevard aux islamistes dans cette
région bref et quant au sénégal car
cette vieille tradition démocratique il
était pour mon malheur puisque l époque
c'était effectivement poste là bas il
était menacé quand même quand même deux
changer de nature avec la velléité du
président wade de fausser le jeu
démocratique et de transmettre le
pouvoir à son fils même s'ils s'en
défendent et
donc dans cette période juste que je
dirais en 2010 en gros c'est pour faire
des choses un petit peu d'aidé
saucissonnée mais nous avions de très
grandes turbulences sur cette afrique
côtière
or depuis 2010 c'est le contraire
revenons à la carte depuis 2010 il ya
des bonnes surprises
la guerre civile en côte d'ivoire c'est
terminé bon on peut contester la façon
dont ça s'est fait l'intervention
française tout ce que voudrait m'enfin
le fait est qu'aujourd'hui la côte
d'ivoire est réunifiée dirigée par un
homme peut là encore discuté mais qui
est qui est tout à fait respectable et
raisonnable on peut le penser
le liberia pareil dirigé par madame
johnson qui est une femme admirable et
pleine de courage la guinée processus
électoral donc
voilà alpha condé a été élu bien mal peu
importe mais enfin il ya eu un processus
électoral il s'est bien déroulé le pays
se développe ya pas de violence il ya
une liberté net le sénégal alternance
démocratique qui s'est bien déroulée
finalement le président wade a accepté
la défaite des urnes et il ya eu une
alternance démocratique normal et la
mauritanie
pour faire bref donc la mauritanie s'est
elle aussi bien redresser alors
mauritanie c'est compliqué parce que
c'est un pays très complexe et un pays
de tribus jette un pays de deux nomades
avec une grande complexité la démocratie
en mauritanie c'est très complexe enfin
le fait est qu au pouvoir aujourd'hui
vous avez un homme qui est l'ancien
général abdelaziz mais qui est un homme
en tout cas qui est arrivé au pouvoir
finalement après une petite intervention
internationale et notamment sénégalaise
de manière démocratique et qui est un
homme raisonnable est en tout cas très
déterminés à lutter contre l'insécurité
dans cette région c'est certainement
aujourd'hui à nos principaux alliés
stratégique dans cette région donc vous
avez en ce moment au terme de ces trois
étapes décrites à grands traits qu'il
faudrait nuancer bien sûr vous avez un
redressement de toute cette zone côtière
l'afrique de cette région fall pas de la
centrafrique je parle pas du de la
république démocratique du congo joue je
parle de l'afrique côtière cette afrique
va mieux cette afrique va mieux et se
retrouve sur la voie du développement et
au fond au milieu de tout ça vous avez
un trou noir qui s'est développé ces
dernières années et ce trou noir c'est
le sar c'est à dire c'est ce qui se
passe non pas sur la zone côtière mais
derrière c'est à dire dans la zone
saharienne
cet immense bande saharienne qu'on ne
représente pas là puisque c'est une
carte politique c'est pas une carte
physique enfin il faut vous imaginer que
de benoît 10 boules de nouakchott là
jusqu en gros à mogadiscio bon avec des
variantes aider les reliefs puis entendu
vous avez une immense zone désertique
gigantesque alors une zone désertique
pour nous le sait la mer de sable
d'ermenonville 6e en gros mais beaucoup
plus grand et en fait ça sert surtout de
lieu de communication c'est à dire que
il passe un monde fou dans le sahara
suffit d'aller camper d'aller passer une
nuit médus à renvoyer des phares partout
et des tas de gens qui passent dans le
sahara et en fait ça a toujours été
comme ça le sahara est une sorte de mer
intérieure
dans lequel circule un des colonnes de
gens de toute nature alors il ya des
rires car and death elles il ya les
nomades et à les peuples nomades comme
les touareg bien sûr les toubous et
cetera qui vivent dans cette région vous
avez les trafics en tous genres je vous
ai parlé tout à l'heure de la cocaïne
colombienne elle arriva bissao mais pour
monter jusqu en europe elle passe par de
très nombreuses voix des voies aériennes
des voies maritimes mais aussi de des
voix saharienne très nombreuses vous
avez des trafics d'autre nature présente
le trafic de cigarettes depuis très
longtemps qui semble qu'ils se font
notamment à partir des ports de la
région du bénin
et du togo qui montrent à travers le
sahara enfin le sahara c'est plein de
monde voilà et ce sahara on va le voir
juste après c'est lui c'est deux là
qu'aujourd'hui venaient les menaces
c'est pour ça qu'il faut pas oublier que
dans la décision qui a été prise
d'intervenir dans cette région il ya des
considérations qui nous regardent
sécurité lutte contre le terrorisme mais
il ya aussi et surtout et d'abord
d'abord la réponse à une demande qui à
la demande de tous ces dirigeants de ces
pays d'afrique de l'afrique côtière qui
sont sortis du chaos qui sont sortis de
situations très difficiles qui sont tout
sauf des pantins qui sont tout sauf des
gens qui ont été installés par des
puissances extérieures sont des gens qui
ont gagné des élections au cur gagner le
pouvoir par leurs propres moyens et qui
ont demandé cette intervention parce
qu'ils savent très bien que le pion
malien était essentielle et risquer de
faire tomber tout le domino de cette
bande côtière fragile et qui est en
train de sortir quand même la tête de
l'eau ces dernières années alors rapide
voilà alors parallèlement pour médecins
en parallèle avec ce qui se passe au
dessus du sort juste en rappel mais vous
le savez
dans les années 60 90
les pays du maghreb les pays de ceux de
ce monde arabe était dominé par
essentiellement des grandes figures du
nationalisme arabe nasser et d'autre et
des monarchies pro occidental comme
celle du maroc odeo des miracles terrain
bon après schématiquement depuis 1990
il y à une montée en puissance de
l'islamisme politique dans ces régions
pourquoi 1990 en gros c'est 1992 il
faudrait dire c'est l'annulation de
deuxième tour des élections en algérie
ro
c'est à dire le la fin de l'espoir d'une
d'un islamisme politique légale si je
peux dire et l'arrivée sur la scène de
groupes armés de gens qui étaient
issu de ceux de ce monde et qui ont
commencé à se rebeller pourquoi 1990
aussi parce que c'est la fin de la
guerre en afghanistan la guerre russe en
afghanistan dix ans et tous les groupes
qui avaient été financés par l'ouest
sans qu'on regarde beaucoup de qui il
s'agissait 1 les lecques matière les
lélés al-qaïda terrain se retrouve
maintenant j'allais dire orphelins de la
guerre en afghanistan et vont se mettre
à dos rire d'autres tessin qui sont
beaucoup plus grave est beaucoup plus
lointain est en tout cas ils vont passer
à la lutte armée au niveau mondial alors
bon avec tout le jeu revient pas sur le
11 septembre et autres et toutes les
tous les développements de cette de
cette affaire
c'est quand même important c'est de
savoir que l'islamisme politique
a changé de nature pendant cette période
cette période 90 2010 il a commencé
l'islamisme politique armée radical a
commencé avec une ambition avec des
ambitions nationales c'est à dire que
les islamistes algériens en gros faisait
la guerre en algérie et contre l'armée
algérienne
le l'arrivée là-dedans 2
du modèle al qaïda c'est le changement
de perspective c'est à dire que ces
islamistes à partir de là non plus avoir
à partir du 11 septembre en particulier
n'auront plus comme principal ennemi le
pays dans lequel ils se trouvent mais
une perspective beaucoup plus vaste qui
est celle d'al qaïda c'est à dire d'une
jihad mondial autrement dit frappé les
états-unis la france les ennemis de
l'islam et non pas seulement les pays
dont ils sont originaires
alors c'est pendant cette période que se
déroulera j c'était pas l'objet de cet
exposé près je n'ai pas mis milama fins
qu'il faut bien voir c'est que pendant
c'est pendant cette période que vont se
constituer les groupes armés que nous
nous retrouvons au mali aujourd'hui ces
groupes armés étaient à l'origine des
algériens ce sont des groupes qui ont
commencé comme étant des groupes
donc du gia le du gspc enfin tout c'est
tous ces groupes armés qui est qu'ils
agissaient dans le cadre du de l'algérie
le centre la tête de ces groupes
d'ailleurs se situe dans le nord de
l'algérie esi sont toujours meilleurs
oui pratique des lieux des prises
d'otages etc mais personne n'en parle
bon et puis il ya un certain nombre
d'entre eux qui vont être repoussées par
la répression et qui vont être poussés
ou dans le sahara dire que l'algérie va
en quelque sorte expulsé évacuer ses
ennemis intérieurs
et elle va les évacués dans l'espace
saharien si on peut reprendre la carte
un instant week l'algérie immense
territoire saharien des demandes
frontières sahariennes et ça va être
assez simple au fond l'algérie va
repousser une grande partie de ses
combattants dans cet espace normalement
il aurait dû y mourir je dire que le
temps bonne logique se retrouvait dans
le désert si vous faisiez ça je vais
dire aux uns ou aux autres n'est ce pas
nous je pense qu'on voit la cre est vrai
mais eux pas du tout au contraire au
contraire ils ont trouvé là
avec beaucoup d'intelligence les moyens
de s'organiser de survivre et de se
développer mais de se développer non
plus contre l'as l'algérie mais dans une
perspective mondiale c'est à ce moment
là qu'ils se sont franchisés al-qaïda et
qu'on a créé qu'ils ont créés à partir
de 2005 al qaïda au maghreb islamique
qui est dit bien dans son nom même qu'il
ne s'agit plus de se battre contre
l'algérie mais avec une perspective plus
globale et alors si au coup et me
remettre la carte avec 7,7 cet espace là
ils ont apparemment ils ont résolu le
problème logistique c'est à dire où ils
arrivent à survivre dans le désert ce
qu'ils ont fait assez facilement d'abord
sur des hommes rudes et puis ils ont
noué des liens avec les trafiquants et
qu'un petit peu tout le monde pour
arriver à survivre dans cet espace alors
là c'est le bonheur parce que
vous ne pouvez pas exercer un droit de
suite d'un pays à l'autre autrement dit
quand les mauritaniens poursuivre ces
groupes armés et qu'ils arrivent à la
frontière du mali a surnagé de s'arrêter
vue de l'extérieur la frontière du mali
si rien c'est du sable mais elle est là
et si trans decitre transgresse bien on
ne peut pas les poursuites dont ils ont
utilisé ces groupes armés ont utilisé
cette zone d'une façon très intelligente
en se fondant j'allais dire dans cet
espace morcelée qui n'est pas morcelé
physiquement mais qui mord serait
politiquement et qui leur permet de se
protéger de trouver des refuges dans les
endroits les plus faibles ce qui
continue de faire aujourd'hui derrière
l'autre bonheur qu'ils ont découvert
dans cette région c'est que la technique
qui est utilisée par ces groupes armés
depuis très longtemps et qu'il est
toujours d'ailleurs sans que personne
n'en parle dans le nord de l'algérie
c'est à dire la prise d'otages aurait
été beaucoup plus rentable dans cette
région la prise d'otage en algérie il se
pratique tous les jours sans qu'on en
parle dans l'est dans la région du nord
on prend en otage
voilà qu'un camionneur chef d'entreprise
c'était un peu on paye un petit peu puis
tout le monde s'en fout
dans la région là c'est beaucoup plus
intéressant parce que on a affaire on
peut prendre en otage des occidentaux et
ils sont beaucoup moins protégés au
début je parle je parle des années 2005
et sert à beaucoup des ong beaucoup
d'entreprises beaucoup beaucoup de gens
dans cette région beaucoup de touristes
et donc la prise d'otages est devenue
une industrie qui a été extrêmement
rentable dans un premier temps dans un
premier temps aussi ces groupes armés
ont pris en otage surtout des
nationalités relativement neutre et qui
paye bien les suisses les autrichiens
oui des gens comme ça sérieux discute
pas et
et voilà et les canadiens etc
c'est d'ailleurs très intéressant moi
j'ai rencontré il ya un canadien robert
fowler qui est un diplomate canadien qui
a été pris en otage par parler par les
groupes armés qui restait trois 3 mois
bon pied canadien probablement du
cracher au bassinet qu'elle a été
libérée il m'a raconté que quand il
était avec eux quand ils étaient était
en plein désert donc dans le nord du
mali ils on été gardé bon alors début on
se disait c'est normal les prisonniers y
en ait gardé
réponse disais mais pourquoi ils nous
gardent toute façon même si on s'enfuit
en est dans le désert
ça sert à rien si ridicule
évidemment ils se rendent compte qu'ils
sont gardées c'est pas du tout pour les
empêcher de s'enfuir c'est pour les
abattre immédiatement si une opération
si quelque chose de suspect
arrive au tour ce qui encore une fois il
est à prendre en considération dans ce
qui se passe en ce moment c'est à dire
qu'il faut savoir que la sanction de la
prise au talent c'est la mort c'est la
censure aucune espèce de discussion
possible et donc dans un premier temps
ils ont pris en otage surtout des
nationalités
solvables est peu politisée je dirais et
puis il ya eu un tournant partir de
2007 et ils ont commencé à s'en prendre
à des français hélas la sphère est
devenu plus politique parce que s'en
prendre à des français c'est autre chose
les revendications étaient plus
politiques on a commencé à entendre
parler la sphère du voile des choses qui
à notre intervention en afghanistan fin
des revendications pas uniquement
financière mais aussi d'ordre politique
et c'était contemporain du passage de
ces groupes sous label al qaïda c'est à
dire nous ne sommes plus uniquement des
trafiquants d où des gens qui se battent
dans notre propre pays nous avons une
ambition mondiale beaucoup plus large
pas donc dans cette période va se
constituer vont se constituer ces
groupes armés bon ces groupes armés faut
bien une chose c'est qu'ils sont très
peu nombreux sont très peu nombreux
alors on parlera du mal et tout à
l'heure mais
dans la version
originelle c'est à dire aqmi y
ça représente quelques centaines de
personnes pas plus pas plus qu'ils sont
très bien organisés qui sont très
efficaces mais pas plus
la guerre au mali à démultiplier ce
nombre mais de façon un peu artificielle
parce que l à opérer une fusion avec les
touareg qui ont une autre problématique
on les comptait en disant il ya beaucoup
de monde mais non c'est un mélange et
puis avec da création de groupes
intermédiaires
purement malien alors là pour le coup
comme une sardine et c'est qu'il y avait
une sorte de version est une version
locale un petit peu de ça mais à
l'origine et à la base et pendant des
années les katiba puisque c'est comme ça
qu'on les appelle du nord-mali du sahara
regroupé quelques centaines de personnes
mais avec des dégâts considérables c'est
à dire premiers dégâts disparition des
ong pratiquement pas ce qu'il est
aujourd'hui quand vous dirigez une
orange et envoyer quelqu'un là-bas c'est
je veux dire s'il ya quelqu'un à un
expatrié celles envoyées à la mort bon
donc évidemment
on hésite pourtant ce sont des régions
qui avaient des programmes de
coopération et notamment de coopération
décentralisée très nombreux il y avait
énormément de monde dansait beaucoup
beaucoup des ong dont s'est notamment
beaucoup de cols nos collectivités
locales françaises qui avaient dit
qu'ils avaient au niger au mali terrade
et des programmes de développement
évidemment grande panique il a fallu
retirer tout le monde les touristes ont
disparu c'était dix régions qui vivaient
aussi en grande partie avec le tourisme
tombouctou la vallée du niger mopti pays
dogon bon c'était dans la région
touristique ce tourisme a disparu
et puis dans un étape supplémentaire
évidemment il ya eu un certain nombre
d'événements qui ont touché des zones
industrielles
l'enlèvement des français dans les mines
d'uranium
les français d'areva à arlit dans le
nord du niger et même jusque dans les
capitales puisque vous souvenez des deux
français qui ont été enlevés dans un
restaurant à niamey et qui ont été tués
en essayant quand on essayait de les
libérer donc eu un danger une sorte de
trou noir qui se creusent et dont
l'origine encore une fois et c'est ce
que disent sont toujours dit les maliens
ont toujours dit cette guerre n'est pas
la nôtre cette guerre est importée chez
nous et c'est bon c'est pas totalement
vrai parce que le problème touareg et
maliens entre autres en tout cas ça a
rien mais pour beaucoup le problème
terroriste est un problème importé en
effet c'est un sous produit des
convulsions je dirais du monde arabe qui
s'est développée vers le sud est alors
qu'il est évidemment beaucoup plus
facile pour ces groupes d'essayer de se
développer vers le sud que vers le nord
c'est évident parce que
l'algérie en particulier quand même bon
même s'il ya eu la prise d'otages enfin
l' attaque de la raffinerie récemment
l'algérie c'est une puissance dans la
matière d'une puissance forte puis
savent que bon ça rigole pas exagérer
rien et vu le résultat de la halle
attaque 50 morts bon voilà après on
discute donc c'est évidemment les pays
du sud les pays du sud sont beaucoup
plus fragiles sont beaucoup plus
difficiles et en plus ce sont des pays
qui sont morcelées d'un point de vue
religieux avec des zones de contact
notamment entre chrétiens et musulmans
qui traditionnellement se passait bien
mais qui ont tendance à se passer de
moins en moins bien notamment au nigeria
sur l'effet de groupes locaux comme boko
haram steira qui sont que des filiales
d'ailleurs un de cette semaine cet
ensemble qui ébranle toute cette zone
non peut revenir à la voilà non voilà
alors là dessus se greffe les printemps
arabes là dessus se greffe les printemps
arabes et finalement on a une zone qui
est elle aussi en jeu d'iran en
mouvement rapide mais un peu inquiétant
notamment en tunisie et l'algérie ne
bouge pas le maroc ne bouge pas la
mauritanie tient bon
et puis la libye évidemment est le siège
d'une intervention armée
d'un call pour discuter si vous ça vous
intéresse peu importe ses motivations et
jugements comportent sur cette opération
le fait est que en ouvrant le coffre
fort libyen matière notamment d'armement
et de mercenaires on a apporté j'allais
dire le coup de grâce c'est à dire que
dans cette région centrale qui était
déjà fragile on a fait circuler un
nombre d'armes considérable à la suite
de la guerre en libye on a fait
redescendre dans cette région saharienne
des gens qui se trouvaient en libye et
qui était plus ou moins utilisé par
kadhafi ou contre kadhafi enfin kg et
est en tout cas plus sur le territoire
libyen et qui se sont rabattus sur le
sur le sahara et donc toutes les
conditions a été créé
pour que le mali soit vraiment la zone
où se concentre vraiment et c'est
presque comme une tragédie on voit on
voit les la mise en place de la faire et
on voit que que le que le mali est au
centre de cette de cette
problématique
aujourd'hui alors bon lait je crois que
les le reste de l'inde est exposée
n'avait pas de n'avait pas de rapport
avec ce que je voulais raconter
aujourd'hui oui bah si c'est à dire que
c'est bon on peut c'est surtout sur la
france de l'afrique voilà en disant
c'est un fou une zone de menaces mais
cette date d'avant la
françafrique zone de menacer aussi zones
de coopération a alors eu des menaces
pour les dangers saharien ça j'en ai
parlé bien entendu qui sont des dangers
réels je veux dire que là dessus
face à la confusion mais que 20 je pense
que l'intervention telle qu'elle a été
menée en tout cas bon on peut la faire
des commentaires sur telle ou telle
méthode utilisée mais en tout cas dans
le principe elle était nécessaire elle
était nécessaire parce qu'elle elle
répondait à une demande bien entendu une
demande africaine a nécessité de
stabilisation dans cette région et puis
elle était nécessaire parce que ces
groupes sont à l'évidence ces groupes
terroristes à l'évidence ont pris depuis
man en 2005 comme objectif de frapper la
france ça c'est tout à fait clair lors
leur objectif est de frapper la france
ils n'ont pas à elles sont pas parvenus
encore à faire le joint sécuritaire qui
leur permet d'avoir une correspondance
jédir et 3 direct avec des groupes qui
se trouve ici
autrement dit meira
mohamed merah et abu zayd c'est pas il
n'y a pas encore le joint c'est encore
non mais il est absolument certain que
si un état sous la coupe de ses groupes
s'étaient constituées au mali dans le
centre dans le coeur du sahara
c'était une menace mortelle tout de
suite pour les pays de la zone ça c'est
sûr mais à terme aussi pour nous parce
que leur objectif encore une fois n'est
pas le il n'est plus locale depuis
longtemps il est international et
alors même s'ils ont chacun des requins
des sous-groupes ondes et des agendas
comme disent les anglais est différent
mais parmi eux aqmi reste un ennemi dans
vingt groupes dont l'ennemi c'est la
france c'est tout à fait clair
alors bon jeune de menaces pour quoi bon
le maghreb entre islamisme et réaction
militaire c'est un vieux ça fait déjà un
moment j'avais fait ce truc mais c'est
vrai que bon au fond ça reste ça reste
vrai c'est à dire que au fond quel est
l'avenir aujourd'hui de la tunisie quel
avenir si on élargit
jusqu'à l'egypte de l'égypte la libye
comment les choses vont-elles se
terminer ce qu'il y aura une réaction
militaire une nouvelle dictature une
nouvelle forme de déstabilisation par
les armes ce qu'au contraire l'islam
isme va devenir plus plus radicale plus
rude et
s'aggraver avec évidemment des menaces
directes sur des choses tout à fait
simple comme le roi de la famille 1 sur
le statut de la femme cetera les
libertés publiques et tout ça il ya là
évidemment une zone en ce moment qui est
une zone d'incertitude dix ans pour ne
pas parler de menaces en tout cas
d'incertitude grave et puis l'afrique
subsaharienne pour parler toujours des
menaces après je parle de choses plus
positives
c'est le croisement d'états faibles et
d'une mondialisation qui est très mal
maîtrisé pourquoi les mal maîtrisée
parce que ces pays se sont ouvert les
donc c'est un peu le revers de la
médaille si vous voulez les pays dont
j'ai parlé en disant qu'ils allaient
mieux la côte d'ivoire le sénégal etc il
vaut mieux oui mais ils se sont ouverts
à des tas de partenaires qui ne sont pas
toujours
deux traits des intéressés ni de très
bonnes influences avec les chinois pour
en parler chinois jouent un rôle dans
cette zone et dans bien d'autres zones
d'ailleurs qui est un rôle quand même
évidemment ambigu sont des prédateurs
économiques qui viennent se saisir des
ressources au mépris des règles
écologiques sociales tout ce que vous
voudrez et les africains commencent à
s'en rendre compte des pays qui sont nos
meilleurs amis et les grands champions
de football comme le qatar par exemple
c'était vrai ou les pays du golfe ont
aussi des diplomaties assez ambigu dans
ces pays dont on ne connaît pas
exactement l'effet un terme puis comme
l'iran aussi mots j'ai vécu dans une
période au sénégal où l'irs ont été le
grand amour de du président wade est
il allé tout le temps un terran il
s'embrasser sur la bouche ou presque
avec sur le made in engine c'était des
spectacles difficile mais il ya enfin
mais enfin moi je suis pour l'amour est
pas et donc voilà jusqu'au jour où ils
ont découlé sénégalais ont découvert
dans un bateau qui a été arraisonné je
crois c'était au togo que les iraniens
ont envoyé des armes à la guerrière de
casamance voilà et à ce moment là
rupture des relations diplomatiques fin
du pacs et c'est donc bon la fête
l'effet de ces nouveaux partenaires est
très en vue et un peu inquiétant parce
que évidemment il trouve là matière à
je veux dire à mener des politiques qui
ne sont pas toujours ni très clair ni
trêve ni très favorable avec des choses
aussi donc moi parler les achats massifs
de terres les coréens par exemple qui
achètent des terres arables dans des
quantités considérables on ne sait pas
très bien ce qu'ils veulent y faire en
faire des terrans bon tout ça est un peu
préoccupant est en face de ça des états
qui reste faible on le voit avec la
crise malienne des armées qui reste
relativement faible des structures
étatiques qui reste faible et donc même
quand ça va mieux qu'ils ont besoin
évidemment d'appui très très fort avec
toujours la perspective de crise
alimentaire de
nedved et de écologique aussi les deux
migrations alors ça c'est l'aspect
menace maintenant le dispositif suivante
en même temps
c'est une zone d'influencé qui est dans
laquelle nous continuons d'avoir
vraiment des choses en commun des choses
en commun très important d'abord une
histoire commune vous savez l'histoire
commune elle est difficile à habiter et
je me suis posé ce problème presque tous
les jours au sénégal parce que françois
raconter les difficultés au quotidien
avec le pouvoir sénégalais mais moi j'ai
été plus intéressés de deux d'avoir un
échange avec la société civile avec tout
le monde là-bas avec et c'est vrai qu'un
carnet la france avec ce que peut
représenter le fait que nous sommes
l'ancien colonisateur c'est difficile
pas évident mais en même temps
je me suis rendu compte que très souvent
nous exagérons nous mêmes le caractère
négatif de cette histoire commune cette
histoire commune elle est évidemment
douloureuse évidemment il ya l'esclavagé
évidemment il ya la colonisation
évidemment il y a
bon tout les tous les reproches qui
peuvent nous est fait qu'une qui sont
graves bien entendu mais y'a aussi mais
il ya aussi
une sorte de de partage d des
souffrances des espoirs de l'histoire
tout simplement qui fait que lorsqu'on
parle aux africains dans l'expérience
que j'avais quitté plus tôt sénégal de
tout cela on se rend compte que pour eux
si on n'arrive pas avec une pipe
habilité en bandoulière disant je vois
là je demande pardon si on les laisse
parler sur les laisse s'exprimer leurs
liens avec la france est riche et ils
sont les premiers à revendiquer une
sorte de d'histoire commune avec nous
deux est au fond ce qui ne reproche
c'est presque le contraire c'est presque
de ne pas les considérer suffisamment
comme faisant partie de notre histoire
et de notre peuple et c'est pour ça
qu'ils vivent très difficilement toutes
les restrictions qui sont faites à
l'articulation échange et c'est parce
que eux
continuent d'être quand même très proche
de la france continue d'écouter nos
télévisions continue de jouer au pmu
c'est toujours
bref donc et il ya là une histoire qui
ne faut pas lire uniquement de façon
négative moi j'insiste beaucoup
là-dessus mais je les ai toujours fait
là bas et ça a toujours été très
fructueux parce que c'est la réalité
la langue c'est pareil notre langue
notre langue et tue on peut la voir
comme une langue impérialistes comme
souvenez mais aussi aussi vous savez
c'est aussi la langue internationale de
beaucoup de ces pays et ils en ont
conscience et je crois qu'il ne faut pas
forcément cherché à mettre notre langue
en concurrence avec les langues locales
qui alors dans certains pays elles sont
très nombreuses dans d'autres pays comme
le sénégal y en a une principale 1 le
wolof qui donc un domine il faut se dire
que le français est la première langue
internationale et que cette langue elle
est
elle donne une ouverture considérable et
ceux qui parlent français vont c'est
ceux aussi qui parlent anglais c'est ce
qu'ils vont apprendre le chinois
je n'ai jamais vu personne qui dans ces
pays qui ne parlait pas français mais
qui parlait le chinois jamais vu ça je
n'ai jamais vu personne parler autre
chose que du mauvais anglais quand tu ne
parlais pas français ça va ensemble
c'est à dire que le français est une
porte ouverte vers les autres langues
vers le monde entier et par conséquent
là encore c'est plutôt un atout des
populations mêlée oui évidemment
les liens sont un énorme bond sont des
liens qui sont parfois éphémères les
étudiants qui peut qui viennent donc dix
mille étudiants sénégalais en france par
exemple mais ce sont des liens aussi
beaucoup plus profond avec des mariages
avec des gens qui sont installées avec
des générations 2 3 1 qui vivent en
france et par conséquent là encore c'est
très important des institutions issues
de la décolonisation alors ça c'est plus
discutable mais elle continue d'exister
notamment le franc cfa qui est peut-être
la seule puisque bon l'asecna aussi mais
ça si vous êtes c'est le contrôle aérien
vous savez moins important mais le franc
cfa il y avait toujours des débats sur
le franc cfa ce qu'il faut est ce qu'il
faut pas assez rare mais ça reste quand
même un élément très important de
stabilité monétaire dans ces régions
voilà et puis la france évidemment à
continuer de jouer un rôle dans les
crises récentes mais ce qui ne pouvait
pas figurer là dessus c'était le mali
parce que dans les crises récentes
luciano mauritanie en libye et ces
termes notre rôle même si on considère
qu'il est positif a toujours été
contestée on nous a toujours trouvé des
idées derrière la tête sur la libye
s'était pétrole sur la côte d'ivoire
c'était les ressources locales cetera
bon sur le mali je crois que la france a
joué une carte qui nous a donné un
crédit énorme dans cette région c'est
une des interventions les plus
incontestables dans une histoire récente
et on comprend pourquoi je l'expliqué
ces pays étaient les premiers demandeurs
les premiers demandeurs et été les
premiers à menacer en chaos car on les
aurait laissé tomber et tous les
nouveaux partenaires tous les gens qui
vient de faire du bien ness vous
embrasser les chefs d'état sur la bouche
cela se sont pas précipités y a que nous
qui sommes allés le faire et je crois
que les africains le savent et que nous
avons joué là une carte qui est
considérable pour montrer non pas pour
que c'était une
stupidité de dire que c'est une
opération post coloniale c'est une
stupidité c'est le contraire c'est une
opération qui s est fait à la demande de
pays souverain qui
parfaitement pris conscience que leur
existence même était menacée si on
n'intervenait pas ensuite c'est plus ce
que c'était voilà
oui bon bain cette basket et surtout sur
l' influence beaucoup d'anxiété voilà
c'est vrai que notre notre influence en
afrique et est un peu en perte de
vitesse ou était en perte de vitesse un
golf à le mali va je pense changer
beaucoup la donne cela je vais
m'éloigner un petit peu du le je vais
m'éloigner un petit peu de sa peau pour
conclure autour de la de l'opération
malienne actuelle vous repassez la
suivante oui
ça c'était plus sûr le gmi
oui donc c'était oui c'est sur
l'influent dont il y avait un certain
nombre de dison de
propositions associées l'europe et c'est
très important je veux qu'on n'est plus
seul en afrique c'est évident et les en
matière de coopération notamment l'union
européenne est fondamental très
important on continue trop souvent à
jouer seul est là et c'est vrai que dans
la sphère malienne on à redorer notre
blason mais ce n'est pas une raison pour
se passer de l'europe bien au contraire
une raison plutôt de motiver l'europe à
s'intéresser à l'afrique c'est contraire
à l'or se débarrasser des vieux réseaux
françafrique alors là pour en parler
toute la soirée les vieux réseaux
françafrique sur fond de crocodile n'est
ce pas
ça existe ça existe et ça existera
j'espère de moins en moins j'ai toujours
pensé pour les voir agir pour pour
essayer de résister alors à leur
pression que ces réseaux françafrique ne
résolvent que les problèmes qu'ils ont
créé c'est d'ailleurs quelque chose dans
lequel il excelle
c'est à dire qu'ils vont voir un chef
d'état et lui dit
sarkozy aime pas enfin je peut arranger
ça peut être bon avec un check peut-être
en jce a compris ils vont voir sarkozy
lui disent ces machins m'enfin bon
peut-être arranger ça bref après avoir
jeté le fiel dans la sphère et bien il
sort triomphant il arrange les choses
bref ces réseaux françafrique ne
fonctionne aujourd'hui que comme des
reliquats d'une ancienne politique était
celle de foccart qui avait à ce moment
là un sens on apprécie ou pas la
politique de foccart avait un sens d'une
politique impériale jeté une politique
encore une fois destiné à garder la
mainmise sur un empire et avec un son de
temps de moyens et en mettant les moyens
avec un parfait cynisme ça avait un sens
aujourd'hui ce n'est plus du tout comme
ça que ça fonctionne ce sont des réseaux
qui se sont autonomiser des gens qui
font ce ce business mais ninon contrat
économique
n'est notre position politique ne
dépendent de ces gens là et c'est même
le contraire parce qu'aujourd'hui quand
vous voulez faire une politique
européenne quand vous voulez travailler
avec les anglais les espagnols et cetera
sur l'afrique la première chose qui vous
disent d'accord mais laissez vos barbus
dehors parce qu'on en a marre de voir
c'est bon alors c'est très très
important et je pense que c'est ce
combat est en train d'être d'être gagné
bon responsabiliser nouveau partenaire
pourquoi parce que c'est vrai qu'on est
un peu tout seul mais un peu tout seul
alors la chine se précipitent pour
signer des contrats y compris quand il
ya un coup d'état fait par un par un
dictateur et se précipite pour une mine
un truc forage n'importe quoi mais les
pays émergents aujourd'hui représentent
une masse très importante qui doit
dégager aussi une coopération si elle
veut être cohérente avec elle-même si le
brésil veut être une grande puissance il
faut qu'il soit si engagée dans la
coopération la russie pareil et même la
chine même la chine dans les réunions de
bailleurs avec l'afrique on peut faire
entrer ces gens là est important de les
responsabiliser
c'est eux qui ont l'argent aujourd'hui
et il faut les associer alors faire
évoluer notre image en afrique bon ça
c'est
pour mémoire et la sécurisation de
l'environnement des affaires où il
s'était pour mémoire c'était pas
vraiment le sujet la dernière des trucs
était évidemment un clin d'oeil mais
ça a été pris sur le vif bien entendu
puisque
chirac était venue était venu à dakar et
ils avaient ils s'étaient après le
discours de dakar donc si vous voulez il
faut y avait un peu de tension est donc
je l'avais pas reçu à la résidence je
l'avais je l'avais invité au restaurant
dans un bon restaurant qu'il aime
beaucoup et puis il m'a dit pendant le
déjeuner il m'a dit mais quand j'ai dit
monsieur président invité ici parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est l'arbre de noël des
enfants la résidence il ya 300 gamins et
mehdi qui donne les cadeaux je ne sais
pas j'y vais
et alors il est venu je me suis caché
derrière un arbre là un arbre vert j'ai
dit de rester derrière je suis venu j'ai
dit aux gamins qui était assis sur les
marches là comme ça j'ai dit vous allez
voir les enfants cette année le père
noël vous savez pas qui c'est et chirac
est sorti en disant bonjour les enfants
il a eu un grand succès
c'est très important ce facteur humain
parce que le savez en afrique plus
qu'ailleurs mais je pense qu'on a fait
que peut-être comme ailleurs mais plus
qu'ailleurs encore parce que
bon là on est entre nous mais je veux le
dire sarkozy pouvait faire ce qu'ils
voulaient malheureusement après le
discours de dakar ils étaient plombés en
afrique voilà
chirac y descendait d'avion il disait
fait beau aujourd'hui tous vents d est
formidable comme il aime l'afrique etc
c'est comme ça et ben voilà alors alors
où en sommes-nous je conclurai là dessus
où en sommes nous avec cette guerre au
mali et je voudrais conclure là dessus
d'abord cette guerre au mali est sorti
un peu j ai pas comme un cheveu sur la
soupe mais en tout cas nous avons coupé
tonné tous ceux qui s'intéressent à ces
sujets parce que ce gouvernement enfin
depuis l'élection présidentielle on
n'avait pas l'impression que l'afrique
faisait partie vraiment des sujets
prioritaires nous avons misé à fait
étranger un cas très grande qualité mais
qui n'est pas vraiment orienté sur les
questions africaines
nous avons un ministre de la coopération
qui a disparu on l'a remplacé par un
ministre du développement mais qui est
un écologiste et qui est plutôt un
ministre du développement durable qui
est un homme assez dogmatiques compétent
mais c'est dogmatique sur les questions
de développement durable terra qui voit
l'afrique par ce prisme un beaucoup plus
environnemental que social même s'il
s'en défend je veux dire c'est quand
même comme ça
bon donc l'afrique avait un peu disparu
des écrans radar et puis elle est
revenue au premier plan avec cette
intervention ça n'est pas forcément plus
mal que finalement on se soit pas occupé
de l'afrique parce que pendant cette
période finalement on a un peu purger le
système justement notamment des vieux
réseaux françafrique c'est vrai que ces
derniers mois les réseaux françafrique
qui ont été un peu mis au régime sec ils
n'étaient plus reçus ni à l'elysée n'est
nulle part bon il ya eu aussi une
normalisation c'est à dire que la
cellule africaine de l'elysée a été
réduite confier à quelqu'un qui est
plutôt juniors 10 ans et les affaires
africaines sont redevenus les affaires
étrangères c'est à dire qu'elles sont
devenues la compétence du quai d'orsay
avec une direction afrique qui comme la
direction amérique comme la direction
asie cetera au moyen-orient a pris je
vais dire l'autorité sur cette politique
ce qui est une bonne chose car elle le
fait de voir ce domaine réservé purement
purement et lysiens n'est pas normal et
ça fait ça contribué à rendre les
affaires africaines au pack donc tous à
être plutôt plutôt bien cette opération
encore une fois elle et
elle était nécessaire j'en suis
convaincu a été courageuse il faut
saluer cette décision parce qu'elle a
été certainement difficile à prendre je
veux dire
elle est dangereuse à terme parce que si
effectivement la présence française se
prolonge dans cette région il peut y
avoir pire des dangers dans la mesure où
ces groupes sont des groupes qui ne sont
formés que à la guérilla donc ça
relativise la victoire militaire si vous
voulez parce que c'était quand même pas
la quatrième armée du monde qu'on avait
en face de nous c'est normal qu'avec
quatre mille hommes il est d'étaler
normal mais les connaissances comme on
les observe depuis des années ces
groupes sont toujours là simplement ils
sont disséminés et ils vont pratiquer la
guérilla cette guérilla s'est pas non
plus l'aghanistan faut pas non plus
exagérer pour plusieurs raisons d'abord
n'y a pas de population locale ou très
peu
donc c'est beaucoup plus difficile pour
eux de se cacher et deuxièmement le il
ya un antagonisme évident entre les
groupes touareg en particulier les
groupes de population locale et ces
groupes au fond algérien essentiellement
d'origine même s'ils sont un
regroupement un peu large qui sont les
groupes d'aqmi donc on n'a pas en face
de nous un ennemi très très solide et je
pense qu'on va revenir à une situation
dans laquelle nous aurons le problème
touareg 1 qui reste là qui est
inquiétant
complètement malheureusement entier ce
qui n'est pas réglée du tout il va
peut-être même s'aggraver pour la mesure
où les touareg jouer un jeu dangereux
d'alliances avec les islamistes mais à
part ça on va avoir acquis mist dire 300
bonshommes qui se balade dans le désert
et qui seront plutôt en plus mauvaise
posture qu'avant parce qu'ils n'ont plus
de base ils sont bombardés l'armée
algérienne les bombardes et c'est donc
je crois que voilà faut pas exagérer les
dangers mais en tout cas il faut
repartir assez vite avec une des
composantes interafricaine qui se
développe je trouve un peu un peu
méprisant si vous voulez la façon dont
on parle désormais des armées africaines
mauger assister puisque nous avons une
grosse coopération militaire avec le
sénégal à des à des manoeuvres
conjointes entre les armées sénégalaises
burkinabé etc et je trouvais des soldats
qui sont de bonne qualité qui sont
d'ailleurs engagés dans les opérations
de maintien de la paix depuis très
longtemps un des sénégalais dans
beaucoup d'opérations de maintien de la
paix qui sont des gens de valeur que
l'onu apprécie beaucoup donc ils sont
peut-être pas armés pour faire une
reconquête bon ça c'était certain mais
en revanche pour assurer la sécurisation
d'une zone qui aura été les dires libéré
entre guillemets nettoyer des
terroristes ils s'en sont parfaitement
capables notamment les tchadiens qui
sont très bien équipés les nigériens
aussi et aujourd'hui notre point d'appui
en matière militaire c'est surtout la
mauritanie qui ne crie pas sur les toits
mais quand il s'agit d'utiliser des
hélicoptères d'attaqué des eaux des
avions un peu voyant on l'aimait plus
tôt a atteint aujourd'hui cac à dakar
donc on voit là cet ensemble mais je
crois que pour finir
lutte contre le terrorisme non ce n'est
pas comme ça qu'il faut présenter cette
affaire nous avons libéré contribué à
libérer un pays africain et nous
n'allons pas nous lancer dans une guerre
contre le terrorisme comme l'avait fait
george bush il faut savoir s'arrêter se
dire que nous avons répondu à une
demande que nous avons rempli une
mission et que maintenant il faut s'en
aller et passer à autre chose qui est de
dire pourquoi sommes-nous allés là parce
que nous tenons à cette afrique parce
que nous tenons à ce qu'elle soit cas et
mieux ce qu'il cas et parce que nous
restons plus que jamais des partenaires
de cette région du monde des partenaires
pour son développement et pour le nôtre
parce que notre destin qu'on le veuille
ou non est liée à ces régions voilà
merci beaucoup
bon c'était très bien traders enfin vous
avez vu très intéressant prêts très
enrichissant très éclairant
simplement ça a été un peu plus long que
notre coutume
ne nous y invite donc je vous propose
cinq questions
sachant que j'ai leur ont
affiché au fond cinq questions
et alternativement masculines et
féminines comme c'est notre habitude
alors pourriez vous nous parler des
problèmes touareg au mali qui
je voulais parler des conflits touareg
au mali qui ont déjà provoqué beaucoup
de conflits armés depuis une vingtaine
d'années merci
tu réponds que
c'est un sujet c'est un sujet très
compliqué parce que les touareg ne sont
pas seulement au mali et il n'y a pas
que des touareg au nord du mali vous
avez des populations notamment les sons
rail qui sont très nombreux dans cette
région et qui des populations d'origine
arabe etc qui ne
vois pas du tout d'un bon oeil le fait
de faire une équation touareg égale sarr
ya pas que les soirées comme ça et les
touareg sont dans l'ensemble de cette
région c'est à dire qu'ils sont aussi au
niger ils sont aussi en algérie ils sont
au nord du mali et sont même dans
l'ouest dans l'est de la mauritanie le
problème c'est que le iie sont ils ont
été à l'évidence discriminer c'est une
évidence un pendant des années est une
des conditions qui a été mise c'est la
pression faite sur le gouvernement
malien pour ne pas revenir au statut
précédent et faire en sorte que voilà
que les que les touareg progresse disons
dans l'eure dans leurs revendications
mais le problème c'est que ils ont mis
la barre très haut parce qu'ils en
avaient déclaré leur indépendance avec
mennella qu'ils ont fait des alliances
désespérée mais dangereuse ils se sont
retournés après d'accord mais qu'ils ont
fait alliance avec les islamistes et
qu'on ne va pas leur pardonner
facilement donc je crains que le prime
touareg aujourd'hui soit plutôt plus
difficile à résoudre qui ne l'était
auparavant et je ne pense pas je sais
que pour l'heure participé à de nombreux
débats avec des maliens de skhira je
sais qu'à chaque fois qu'on parle de
cette situation et qu'on arrive au
problème touareg
ça se durcit terriblement et les maliens
du sud qui sont je vous rappelle les
anciens esclaves des territoires il mais
c'est pas la seule raison c'est pas la
seule raison sont extrêmement
raide sur ce sujet donc je là dessus je
ne vois pas du tout les
filières
ou note en bas de page est ce qu'il n'ya
pas maintenant
une possibilité inédite
d'une ambiance détendue parce que
peut-être les toits peuvent être les
alliés du gouvernement malien dans la
surveillance de ces zones qui autrement
vont servir de refuge à la guérilla que
tu évoquais il semble que du point de
vue de la dynamique
géostratégique du coin une petite porte
risque de s'ouvrir
c'est possible mais j'en doute un peu
parce que ça marche avec nous c'est à
dire qu'ils peuvent nous fait peuvent
nous dire ça ils vont jouer ce jeu
d'ailleurs parce qu'ils ont capturé des
captures et des dirigeants des groupes
islamistes ivry sont en train de les
interroger comme on dit c'est à dire
probablement doit être un peu rude et
ils vont nous donner les renseignements
ils vont nous expliquer ce qui est donc
qu ils jouent le jeu avec les français
d'une coopération dans la lutte contre
l'islam et ça ça marche avec nous mais
je ne suis pas certain que ça marchera
que gouvernement malien pour plusieurs
raisons on a beau revenir cet
antagonisme profond qui est quand même
là et puis parce que ça a été utilisé
que ça n'a pas marché ça a été utilisé
par att
amadou toumani touré qui était là était
le dernier président avant le coup
d'état
et ce
traité ne nous le disait moi j'ai
rencontré plusieurs repêché fois qu'on
lui parler de ce sujet disait vous ne
vous inquiétez pas on s'en occupe nous
avons sous traiter le problème la
sécurité au nord alors c'était pas aux
touareg c'était aux tribus berabiches
pas aux tribus arabes du nord et qu'est
ce qu'ils ont fait les ans et les ans
financé les un peu armes et caetera puis
un jour ou l'autre un jour ces tribus se
sont en fait révélé dans l'autre sens
c'est à dire infiltrée par les
islamistes et se retournant contre eux
donc c'est très très très très compliqué
est bon on verra on verra je pense que
nous devons adopter une position simple
qui consiste à avoir une position
j'allais dire morale
qui peut pas être une position
d'ingérence mais qu une position forte
en ce qui concerne les droits qu'on les
touareg d'être respectés d'avoir une
certaine hauteur d autodétermination
de détermination pas un mot qui qui peut
on peut pas aller jusque là mais en tout
cas avoir une certaine autonomie dans
leur dans la gestion de leurs affaires
voilà c'est tout ce qu'on peut c'est
tout ce qu'on peut demander la façon
dont ça va se résoudre je ne sais pas
bonjour vous avez évoqué la démocratie
naissante en afrique vous avez également
évoqué les printemps arabes
qui est effectivement est due à la mise
en réseau de la planète avec internet
quel rôle parce que pensez vous que va
jouer la démocratie dans les échanges
afrique france dans le développement du
e-commerce peut-on passer de la
démocratie un petit peu en panne à l'aïs
démocratie
totale
oui merci moi je voulais revenir à
l'algérie parce qu'en fait je le
sentiment dans l'opinion française on ne
vous comprend pas bien les évolutions
terrible depuis 90 de l'alluré et sa
part est liée à tout ça parce que au
moment du printemps arabe l'algérie llc
comme d'habitude avec sa dictature
militaire et c'est bien ready et puis on
a quand même l'algérie qui incapable de
maîtriser son propre sud le sud proche
et les confins du sahara c'est une
puissance saharienne centrale
donc en fait comment peut-on arriver à
impliquer l'algérie pour nous aider pour
dire vous choisissez votre camp parce
que oui parce que pour l'instant où
sont-ils qui sont très isolé
diplomatiquement l'algérie
oui alors se loger
sur l'algérie je trouve que je
ce gouvernement notre le nôtre a mené à
bien jouer parce que ils ont quand même
redresser une situation qui n'était pas
évident jusqu'à cette intervention le
credo c'était de diriger l'inacceptable
jamais une intervention internationale
et en particulier française dans son
arrière-cour saharienne c'était le
bulgare on disait ça et puis il ya eu la
visite de laurent fabius de l'orne et
c'est bon ils ont ils ont vraiment bien
joué parce que ils ont fait comprendre
et on sentait que c'était mur il y avait
un certain nombre d'évidences comme quoi
on ne pouvait expliquer aux algériens
les égyptiens avaient déjà compris tout
seul que il pouvait se satisfaire
d'avoir quelques gugusses qui courait
dans le sahara pendant comme ça se
faisait et qui aurait qui embête et les
autres en gros c'était sage quelle
période récente bon c'était aqmi c'était
quelques centaines de types dans
lesquelles il y avait quelques agents
d'ailleurs infiltrer les algériens
savaient très bien ce qu'ils faisaient
et qui se baladait pas chez eux et qui
laissait un peu de trouble dans le
système quand on est un régime militaire
c'est pas mal de voir un petit peu
trouble autour me permet de justifier
aussi le maintien d'un certain nombre de
mesures de sécurité d'exception donc
tout ça c'était très bien et puis
quand les islamistes ont avancé vers le
sud du mali ils se sont rendus compte
que ce qu'ils allaient avoir c'était un
état touareg est un état terroriste à
leur porte et là c'était plus pareil
c'est plus pareil c'était plus un truc
qui se baladent c'est plus des gens qui
baldassarra donc c'était un état touareg
ils n'en veulent pas c'est long c'est
leur bête noire et un état
islamiste et qui plus est peut-être même
un état touareg islamistes à dire
vraiment l'horreur totale
à leurs portes de façon incontrôlée est
donc assez intelligemment je trouve on a
fait comprendre aux algériens que voilà
leur intérêt à ce moment était là ils
ont pris le risque aussi puis ils ont
laissé passer nos avions et qu'ils ont
une certaine manière payer quand vous
étiez ne contrôlent pas leurs sud bien
sûr il ya eu cette affaire dans la dans
la raffinerie ce qu'il faut dire c'est
que ça c'est pas passer n'importe où ça
s'est passé en face de la libye c'est à
dire dans une zone qui est une zone
éminemment déstabilisé par la guerre en
libye sur le son clair
et dans laquelle les algériens se sont
trouvés pris en défaut mais vous avez vu
avec quelle violence ils ont réagi et je
pense qu'on va pas le refaire le coup
deux fois que là ils ont ils ont
vraiment redéployer leurs forces et
qu'en ce moment il ya vraiment bon c'est
un peu le mur de l'atlantique donc je
pense que l'algérie sont quand elle l'a
choisi c'est tout à fait clair elle elle
elle est fermement
opposé à l'existence d'un de d'état ou
de forme constituée de groupes radicaux
islamiques dans la région bon
jusqu'où iront à notre que leur
coopération avec nous ça faut pas non
plus espérer que ça allait trop loin
mais là on a quand même réussi à se
mettre en phase avec ses très bien sur
le e-commerce la démocratie je suis pas
sûr d'avoir compris votre question je ne
suis pas tellement un hic conférencier
moi même et j'ai je manque de ce qui est
certain c'est que pour ce qui est de dix
ans de du rôle des rôles des
cessa de votre question mais le rôle d
des réseaux sociaux en afrique en
afrique noire est assez réduit parce que
bon c'est ça fonctionne quand même
beaucoup moins bien même s'il ya
beaucoup de téléphones portables dans
ces régions et finalement je vais dire
qu'en afrique subsaharienne on n'a pas
besoin de ça c'est une des choses qui
m'a le plus frappé d'ailleurs à d'aquin
c'est que lorsqu'il ya quelque chose qui
se passe d'émeutes pour des raisons qui
sont parfois des raisons tu te fais
économiques notamment ceux se passeront
des coupures de courant des inondations
terrain les choses vont extrêmement vite
en afrique c'est à dire que vous avez
immédiatement des milliers de gens dans
la rue qui vont se mettre en phase et
ils n'ont pas besoin de réseaux sociaux
pour ça et à ce moment là l'ambassadeur
devient une sorte de préfet dont le rôle
est d'assurer que de s'assurer que les
enfants concerts du lycée français vont
bien pouvoir rentrer chez eux et ça va
très très vite donc si vous voulez
l'afrique connaît ces phénomènes avec
les marchés avec les marchands ambulants
etc sans avoir vraiment besoin de 2
delahaye de l'aï en fait voilà et donc
voilà mais cela dit compte pour ce qui
est de la démocratie en elle même si
vous voulez
ça reste un sujet comme sensibles cette
question cette question vous avez des
pays le c'est le cas du sénégal qui ont
une vraie culture démocratique c'est
fascinant le sénégal et les sénégalais
depuis des années sont habitués à
s'exprimer par les urnes avec avec une
grande que nantes pertinence et
finalement la menace à laquelle nous
étions confrontés à cette période de
transition la période de wad c'était
justement que ce système ne fonctionne
plus soit bloquée et qu'à ce moment là
le peuple se révolte parce qu'on le
frustré de sa de son vote si vous voulez
maintenant vous avez d'autres pays où
c'est beaucoup plus compliqué parce que
il n'ya pas cette tradition parce qu'il
ya une instrumentalisation des partis
politiques par des ethnies et c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué ça reste un
sujet très sensible à cette question de
la technique démocratique en afrique
bonsoir je voudrais revenir une seconde
sur l'algérie est ce qu'il est faux de
dire que les algériens n'ont pas été
très vigilant dans l'approvisionnement
en carburant des islamistes sachant
qu'il est admis que c'est là qu'ils
s'approvisionnent qui a pas trop dans le
nord-mali de stations-service en ce
moment
oui mais les islamistes vous savez ils
sont
ils ont des relais nombreux et c'est
très intéressant de les voir fonctionner
moi j'ai écrit un roman est reçue
s'appelle katiba qui était justement que
j'ai fait ça quand j'étais ambassadeur
parce que j'ai pas beaucoup le temps de
faire autre chose enfin je veux dire de
faire un livre plus plus documenté sur
autre chose que sur ce que j'ai sous les
yeux et ça m'a fasciné parce que s'ils
voulaient changerait beaucoup j'étais
très relativement informés sur ces
sujets puisque nous
disposons d'un certain nombre de moyens
quand même pour savoir ce qui se passait
donc c'est dans ces pays dans ces
groupes
ils vont pas vrai dans tout leur
matériel que ce soit le carburant le
matériel électronique ou les voitures
voyez rarement un barbu avec un chèche
et de mitraillettes entrait sur un
concessionnaire et dire je voudrais une
toyota comme ci ou comme ça ça se fait
pas comme ça ils ont des relais ils ont
des intermédiaires ils ont des gens qui
leur servent de poisson pilote même pour
prendre les otages d'ailleurs on sait
très bien que il ya des groupes
intermédiaires qui souvent capture
l'otage qui leur vendent qui le
fournissent et c'est donc ils ont des
tas de moyens de s'approvisionner et je
suis pas sûr que algérien de ce point de
vue puissent tout contrôler je suis pas
sûr non plus que le pétrole viennent
forcément de chez eux c'est c'est très
très compliqué mais ce qui est sûr c'est
qu'ils ont à peu près tout ce qu'il faut
et que avec la crise en libye si vous
voulez on a là un pays qui lui est
totalement incontrôlée donc c'est plus
facile encore de se fournir la voie là
et je rends que la libye sur les si le
problème se déplace en ce moment
aujourd'hui plutôt vers la passe que
l'algérie s'est fait prendre en défaut
mais va réagir la libye
il n'y a pas grand monde au bout du fil
pour le moment je veux dire
une réflexion à une question la première
réflexion mais tu l'as dit je pense que
c'est stratégique pour l'europe d'avoir
une enfin une stratégie avec l'ensemble
du continent africain qu'au fond elle
est en train de commercer d'avoir des
relations avec les états unis la bike
latine l'inde le japon le canada et
après demain la chine et que le
continent qui n'attend à notre proximité
nous n'avons aucune même réflexion
stratégique européenne sur la question
de l'afrique donc moi je pense que dans
la décennie qui s'ouvre ça doit être un
des points fondamentaux de l'action et
de la réflexion européenne
alors on va pas revenir là dessus
maintenant parce que ce serait très long
mais je pense que la proximité de ce
continent et de l'europe les intérêts
convergent les histoires communes entre
un paquet d'états membres et les pays
africains tout cela fait que tu as parlé
de nouveaux partenaires tout à l'heure
il y a un partenaire ancien et légitime
qui devrait être là qui devrait être
l'europe ça c'est la première inflexion
que je voulais faire et la deuxième
c'est une question tu as parlé de la
difficulté tout à l'heure avec les
touareg est ce que tu crois à
l'hypothèse politique d'une
réconciliation entre le sud mali et le
nord-mali pas s'il ya bien un moment où
quand on va se retirer et assez
rapidement la question de la guerre sera
derrière nous même s'il reste évidemment
je suppose des conflits potentiels dans
le sahel est évident est compris dans le
nord du mali mais ce que tu crois à
l'hypothèse poussé en cela par la france
par l'europe n'est pas d'une
réconciliation réelle au fond entre le
sud manier le nord mali
difficile
non je non je ne crois pas je pense que
ce sont des pays qui reste hétérogène
qui le resteront que des antagonismes y
en a à peu près partout dans ces pays
qui en a eu aussi longtemps et qui en a
peut-être encore aussi en aujourd'hui
dans notre propre pays que il faut pas
nécessairement considérer qu'un état ne
peut fonctionner que s'il est totalement
harmonieux et si c'est le pays des
bisounours
je pense qu'un état c'est aussi la scène
sur laquelle se joue des antagonismes
c'est à dire que la question de savoir
si l'état malien pourra demain faire
cohabiter des gens qui ne vont pas
forcément s'entendre parce qu'au fond ça
je veux dire je suis pas certain qu'on
arrive à les faire s'entendre sens voilà
il ya des il ya des antagonismes fort
bon mais vous savez sur les états
africains moyenne chose qui me choque
toujours beaucoup c'est quand on dit ils
sont mal fichu ils sont mal découpé bon
c'est vrai que si on remonte à
l'histoire coloniale et la première
histoire coloniale celle des découvreurs
en particulier portugais tous les petits
tous les pays qui sont sur la côte là
sont des comptoirs c'est à dire qu'ils
ont été créés par un port et puis à
l'arrière du port et bien on a tracé de
ligne et puis c'était le pays qui était
derrière voilà bon c'est exactement la
même chose d'ailleurs dans le nord du
brésil vous avez le pernambouc etc qui
sont gré comme ça mais c'est comme ça
alors forcément ils ont ces pays ont
traversé des zones de population
traditionnelle qui sont différents quand
vous allez du togo au sud jusqu'au nord
vous traversez d un millefeuille de
populations qui elles sont distribuées
en bandes horizontales bon c'est comme
ça mais
dire se dire que à cause de ça ces états
ne sont pas viables et qu'il faut les
redécouper je crois que c'est plus du
tout le sujet quand vous allez dire un
sénégalais ou à ou un camerounais tient
une telle zone tiens tu crois pas que tu
devrais la donner à ton voisin parce que
agen les galeries mais de quoi tu parles
là ça fait 60 ans qu'on est indépendant
je veux dire on vieillit comme ça on
voit là il ya une conscience d'état qui
se crée dans ces pays elle s'est créée
je veux dire
voilà et donc la question c'est de
savoir si les régimes politiques sont en
place en particulier démocratique votre
vote mais que je dire que la structure
dans laquelle les choses se passent peut
contenir ces oppositions et leur
permettre de s'exprimer autrement que
par la violence voilà c'est ça la
question maintenant pour le reste ils
sont comme ça et si vous regardez où
sont les conflits aujourd'hui en afrique
je ne parle pas des conflits importer
cette histoire de khatib je parle des
conflits locaux il se passe aux endroits
où le découpage colonial n'est pas clair
par exemple la péninsule de bakassi
entre nigeria et cameroun péninsule qui
se prolonge par des zones sous-marines
pétrolière la frontière comme nearly mal
est mal définie bon c'est là qu'il ya
des cas des tensions importantes parce
que les mal définis mais dans les
endroits où les frontières sont définis
aujourd'hui ces frontières sont habités
par les états et dire on va tout
balayer puis on va tout reconstruire
autrement ça n'est absolument pas le
sujet et personne ne le soit personne ne
le veut donc la question c'est de savoir
comment faire en sorte que ce soit dans
la pacifique menée sur l'europe je peux
évidemment que souscrire à ce que tu dis
en sachant que c'est quand même à la
france de porter ce message en europe
parce que pour beaucoup de pays
l'afrique c'est vraiment ça n'existe pas
c'est à dire que ces sondes et ils ont
des réseaux diplomatiques qui sont très
très
enfin un peu peu développé dans ces pays
là ils ont peu d'informations sur ce qui
s'y passe éboue rezé volley là le
problème 1 c'est vers l'est c'est vers
l'asie s'étira et nous avons une
conscience africaine qui est qui est
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus développé de
par l'histoire que les autres et c'est à
nous je crois de de mettre ces sujets en
avant
merci infiniment alors je vais en une
minute
d'abord vous dire
la gratitude que nous avons
à l'égard de christophe d'avoir animé
cette très intéressante d'ailleurs votre
silence permettait d'entendre l'intérêt
de la contribution de l'exploser de la
présentation et de la réflexion de jean
christophe rufin
deuxièmement dire simplement un mot de
la situation moi je considère que nous
venons de vivre un moment très important
depuis un mois très important très
important bien sûr pour françois
hollande pour le gouvernement parce que
il a révélé aux yeux des français
quelque chose que les gens ne
soupçonnait pas et c'était réellement à
un moment crucial parce que c'était à
faire deux jours et peut-être même
affaire d'heures
est rarement
autant de gens se sont sentis re en
phase avec une décision qui d'habitude
ce sont des décisions ignorer ou
controversés on est entre nous
ici si j'ose dire
c'était pour moi beaucoup moins évident
la sphère libyenne beaucoup moins
évident
j'avais posé la question y compris à la
tribune comment on sort d'un truc comme
ça et
c'est
clair qu'on en met mal sorti tandis que
là la question était d'un basculement
extraordinairement dangereux pour la
région et pour nous
quand un pays à 6000 personnes sur place
eh bien il n'est pas à l'aise quand les
preneurs d'otages prennent le pouvoir
d'état
ça c'est la première chose la deuxième
chose je vais ici
m'inscrire en faux avec la grande
contradiction avec la plupart des choses
qu'on entend
moi je suis très
heureux au fond que la france c'est eu
la capacité
la volonté la détermination d'y aller si
vite et même tout seul moi je trouve ça
très important
parce que vous savez à quel point la
question nationale la question de caisse
que nous sommes france qu'est ce que
nous représentons est-ce que c'est fini
est ce que et tout d'un coup là on avis
on a vu toucher du doigt que rien
n'était usurpé de ce que nous croyons de
notre histoire
par exemple la question qui a été si
souvent posées par des parts d esprit
critique
de notre siège au conseil de sécurité
ben là on a vu
il n'ya pas beaucoup d'états dans le
monde qui peuvent faire ce que nous
avons fait en europe il n'y en a que
deux la grande bretagne et nous et c'est
les deux qui ont le siège au conseil de
sécurité
et quand on regarde autour de nous
la perception que les états peuvent
avoir de leurs homologues de leurs
partenaires je suis sûr que c'est une
réévaluation alors pour l'instant le
voit pas ça peut être discuté et je
maintiens cela y compris si nous
rencontrons des difficultés parce que
bien sûr on peut en rencontrer
mais ces difficultés là quelle qu'elle
soit
et nous devront serrer les coudes
s'édifie elles sont infiniment moins
grave que ce qui se serait passé si nous
nous étions perdus en discussions
interminables dans des comités des
commissions d g 8 32 24 et que au bout
du compte
nous ayons été les révélateur de
l'impuissance
des états dans une situation critique
donc moi je trouve que c'est vraiment
très très important et que évidemment ça
nous donne une responsabilité marielle
en europe
ce que jean christophe vient de dire
c'est à dire que nous sommes en europe
pas n'importe quel pays nous sommes un
pays qui à cette profondeur de champ
comme on dit en matière de photo
profondeur de champ historique
profondeur de champ géopolitique nous
sommes ceux qui avons quelque chose à
dire de cette réalité là un grand nombre
d'autres partenaires européens qui n'ont
pas la même perception ce qui veut dire
bien entendu on a mesuré un certain
nombre de faiblesses et d'insuffisance
de l'europe mais à nous de corriger les
faiblesses et les insuffisances
emportant quelque chose qui devrait
normalement être
mutualisées au sein de l'union
européenne
je dis souvent
si on mesure est ce que les anglais avec
leurs connaissances de leurs
grandes zones historiques et nous avec
la connaissance de notre zone historique
si nous mettions en commun ces deux
influences et ses deux expériences ben
le monde serait pas le même et
normalement l'europe devrait servir à ça
en tout cas c'est la proposition que
nous ferons jean christophe rufin a été
formidable et vous avez été formidables
d'être là merci beaucoup
oui nous nous voyons le 26 février avec
jean jacques aillagon